foreign
[Music]
I am the NGS core manager at the La
Jolla Institute for immunology and today
I'm going to talk about an essay that we
developed in The Institute it's a saliva
based rtpcr SARS cov2 detection assay
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
deployment and the development of this
test
or screen
I'd also like to thank the organizers
for inviting me to do this recording
today
so in summary it's a one-step rtq PCR
assay uses the CDC novel coronavirus
real-time PCR diagnostic panel it
effectively detects star cov2 particles
from saliva samples
heat and activation together with direct
lysis with detergent actually eliminates
the need to extract the RNA we've got it
down to a six microliter low volume LV
reaction and that performs well
just going to talk a little bit about
the normal test life cycle so in
normal times we start with the
feasibility and design of a test move
into development sketch out the
validation all the equipment matrices
that need to be tested you do
preliminary evaluations and then you
verify and then you're ready to launch
you keep it maintained until it's ready
for retirement however during a pandemic
this is the test life cycle pandemic
Edition so although I put the talk
together in a couple different ways the
way I'm going to go through it is more
or less chronologically so I'm not going
to talk about for example stability and
go through every iteration of every
stability test
at once I'm going to take you through
more chronologically just to highlight
the way that development can be quite
different during
the pandemic and when resources are not
as readily available as we may be used
to to borrow phrase from Lisa Covington
from the express which I'll talk about a
little bit later she said we're
building the plane while we're flying it
so that's sort of what this felt like
and I just kind of want to go through
that and because it was such a unique
time to be designing something
the format I'll just introduce each
stage Define the objective and I'll give
a result summary a tldr too long didn't
read the methods I'm pretty much going
to Breeze through if you have any
questions you can look me up and I'm
happy to give any protocols or details
offline and then I'll go through the
detailed results where I'll show the
figures
um the objectives that I'd like to
convey through this talk will be to
describe the advantages and
disadvantages of a saliva based assay of
an RNA a free extraction free assay to
detect upper respiratory pathogens
specifically in this case rcob2 and just
talk about the flexibility and Agility
of PCR based protocols
some of the more common abbreviations
I'm going to use some of the more
important ones would be the n and the N1
and N2 is the COV nuclear capsid
RP is going to be human rnasp so that's
going to serve as our human control LOD
limit of detection and the rest are
pretty normal
um Nan not a number so that shows up in
some of our PCR results and
so why are we as an independent academic
Institute deciding to put a screen
together well as home to some of the
world's top immunologists it wasn't
really an option for us to shut down so
instead we had to double down
researchers at lji contributed to some
of the most important coveted research
throughout this entire pandemic so we
the NGS core were challenged to develop
and Implement a screen that would be
simple for our employees to do on a
regular basis and ensure they could keep
coming into work and doing the important
research that had to be done we needed
to balance sensitivity with ease and the
saliva-based assay fit that bill this is
Dr fauci highlighting some work from two
of our researchers Dr sette and Dr
Crotty on T-cell immunity so this work
was informing policy as well
um so I'm going to start at the very
beginning the proof of concept the
objectives were just would it work could
we take the CDC probes as they were and
the IDT nuclear capsid positive control
and just get it to work in the assay as
we had
sketched it out
um in the results summary yeah it worked
the NPC didn't amplify the COV did
amplify in the positive rnasp we found
in normal saliva so we figured out a few
things one is all these probes work keep
in mind at this time all the ruo and the
eua versions of these probes and primers
were all
um fan based so this couldn't be
multiplexed quite yet
we tried two concentrations of trade
necks as the detergent to lysosal saliva
we didn't attempt to extract the saliva
at all we went right into a direct
license protocol and if that didn't work
then we would have stepped backwards and
looked into extraction however we were
surprised well I'm not surprised but
please define that it did work quite
well
um
this is just the plate layout of the
titration that we began with the
Positive IDT control the nucleocapsid
the plasmid H2O is NTC and then three
presumed normal saliva samples so these
were not these were saliva samples that
were presumed normal and that they
hadn't been tested in a clinical test
yet to show that they were truly
negative but we just had to presume
negativity until we could show it more
through the assay
so I'm going to go through the slide
here this is the titration the beginning
titration of the plasma control and this
is just in Te and then three normal
saliva samples so we did not detect any
COV in the saliva the human internal
control worked quite well the rnasp
in all three of those the NTC didn't
amplify anything all the plasma did
amplify the plasma so we're good to go
we want to move on to the next step so
in that we had tested two different
Triton percentages for lysis there was a
paper out that had very few samples
um but they use both they think they
used 20 percent we wanted to see if we
could reduce the amount of detergent
that would end up
in the assay so this is a table just
looking at these numbers in the Box you
can see that the negative numbers
are more prevalent and negative CT value
indicates earlier amplification because
this was
um 20 this is 10 minus 20. the CT values
for those and since less detergent is
preferable we proceeded with the 10
percent
looking forward on this we know already
that saliva collection is going to need
to be standardized we're going to need
to write great directions to have people
be able to give a quality sample every
time so we wrote down very
detailed instructions and the team
recorded a video that was available on
YouTube for all our participants to be
able to watch to get a better idea of
how to give a quality sample
um
just a graphic representation we collect
saliva through passive drooling just
into any clean consumable works we
include in the saliva kit a transfer
pipette an empty tube and then a tube
that's filled with a mil and a half of
te so what we ask the participants to do
is to actually make a working stock for
us
um
this solves a few issues one saliva is
viscous and trying to pipette saliva
neat saliva on and liquid Handler is
quite difficult without dripping since
we had
a
population that was very willing to test
for us or to screen
um
and follow directions this was kind of
an easy ask if the population is
different then we've come up with other
ways to collect the saliva without
involving the participant making their
own dilution and then we asked them to
clean off the tubes for us before they
hand them in
one thing we want to do is Multiplex so
as soon as we had the data showing that
the proof of concept was good that these
Pros would amplify I ordered some custom
probes on two of the two of the targets
to make sure we could actually
amplify everything in one well
so we performed a 24-hour saliva
stability just to see what kind of
temperature we could keep the saliva I
once was it was brought into the lab we
did a two-day
process on day one we tested them fresh
day two after storing three aliquots of
each of those fresh samples at 4 minus
20 and minus 80 we did uh the qpcr assay
and quadruplicate again and what we
found was that all storage conditions
were sufficient they returned a
a good result for the RP at all
conditions the minus 80 condition had
lower CTS in general and less deviation
so we stuck with a minus 80 and half
people you can see in this box the
yellow is the fresh
um these obviously weren't on the same
plate because we can't test the fresh
and the 24 hour condition at the same
time
um so again we decided to store the
samples at minus 80. we would like to
test this longer and higher temperatures
um again a plasmid LOD to see if we
could get through
um see if we could determine just the
limited detection of plasma and nte we
also wanted to do a quick thermocycler
equivalency test to make sure we could
use any machine in the building
so we did another COV plasmid
titration NTC and saliva so what we did
was make a double volume plate and then
stamp out one of the plates into the
other one that served
to
uh so we this plate was both the COV
plasma titration and
thermocycler equivalency tests so the
kind of sort of two things here again 10
we can detect pretty reasonably we have
not reached the limit of detection yet
the average CT overall was lower on the
bio red the standard deviation was lower
we're going to go with the bio-red and
use agenda as a backup
more this is just the method of the LOD
we still don't know the LOD to find it
out we're going to have to put it in
saliva
at this point we get four clinically
validated SARS COV samples in-house and
so we can finally move on to testing
them with testing the assay with real
positives this is just the plate layout
of some of the clinical positives so we
tested them neat 50 for some of them
because we didn't have enough volume to
test all of them and 25 I'm not going to
present the 50 data since I don't have
it on everything the way this is laid
out here is samples three four five and
six I showed the neat and then the 25
dilution
and how the the essay functions you can
see sample four doesn't perform very
well sample three is just okay the 25
perform better overall so we realize
here the samples need to be diluted so
we need to optimize
um and continue working on the
clinically validated positives hopefully
we get the multiplexing uh the
multiplexing probes came in soon after
this so what we decided to do is try
this first with the plasmid and not
waste our precious clinical sample
until we know we can get it to work so
what we did is just compare the original
probes that are all fam and we ran the
multiplex version as well on the same
plate the open boxes are the original
and the close boxes are the multiplex
just to make sure that there was no sort
of inhibitory competition between the
primers and probe sets everything worked
well together and in some cases better
this is just a table of those results I
should mention that this was done on
residuals from all four of those first
clinical positives we didn't have enough
volume left to run multiple reactions of
anything on one or four samples so we
combine them all together and called it
a clinical Aggregate and continue some
testing on that
this is the clinical sample so
everything performed well in the
multiplexed reaction so this gives us
good confidence to move forward with
this design
so we're going to continue to optimize
the pros hex is the one that I picked
for N2 it's kind of a noisy probe so
later on we decided to change it
we want to look at the stability of the
positive saliva now so we've
investigated regular saliva and looked
at the RP but now can we still detect
COV particles we assume yes since the
the Amplified regions and the end Gene
are so small it would probably take a
lot of degradation for this to happen
but we're not putting any stabilizers or
preservatives in the saliva collection
too so we just need to be sure that this
is something that will
return a positive result
um
so we go four hours and 24 hours we have
two new clinical samples now eight and
nine this is just a graphic layout of
what we did so there's eight and nine
they were neat they were made into three
aliquots each of 25 and 12.5 percent
those were tested right away at four
hours later they were tested again and
then 24 hours later tested again
and I broke it down by the percentage of
the dilution so here you can see sample
eight performs very well in op
conditions sample nine was viscous and
we learned that viscous samples again
just do not perform very well and this
is going to inform our acceptance
criteria for samples coming into the lab
something that looks extremely viscous
and we can't dilute down
we will probably reject and ask the
person to hydrate very well and try
again to give another sample because
hydration can have a big effect on the
viscosity of the saliva sample coming in
this is a 12.5 dilution again sample
eight performs really well sample nine
has a little bit of amplification here
and there it would have come back as an
inconclusive as how we would have called
this the 12.5 didn't help too much so we
don't think that that's a viable option
for extremely viscous samples at some
point dilution doesn't seem to help all
that much
after if it fails at 25 it's probably
also going to fail at 12.5 is the major
point of that this is just sample eight
looking at the numbers the 25 versus the
12.5 so you can see all the data
together there's fresh four hours and
overnight the darker the blue it is the
more sensitive
um the lower CT so you can see there's
not a huge difference here the 25 works
well fresh four hours and overnight all
work great
um again so we're we know that the
saliva samples can be stored at least
for four hours which mimics the scenario
that we're expecting which is collecting
at home and coming into work even if you
get stuck in traffic four hours should
be enough
so another thing we wanted to do is test
heat and activation
um because he has been shown to
effectively and activate potential SARS
pov2 virus we wanted to make it safer
and sort of increase the logistics
logistical like needs of the lab so it
would give us more flexibility
in the Staffing and the space and the
automation
so what we found was that heat
inactivation actually does not impact
the detection in some cases it enhanced
it so we'll continue to implement this
step upon receipt of all samples and
investigate the stability before and
after heating which we do next
statistics viscous samples actually
performed a little bit better after
heating so this is one thing that kind
of improved the essay a bit
so this was sort of a crazy Matrix test
um
we tested all kinds of conditions that
we might see in the lab which is if we
heat both the stock tube that they hand
in and the dilution tube that they hand
in and later we need to make a dilution
from the heated stock tube
and then heat that does everything work
and does it work if we only use Triton X
and does it work if we only eat it so
all of these things were tested on a
plate uh you there's no way you can see
these numbers but I just wanted to show
The Matrix of this plate and how
detailed we tried to get to imagine
every scenario that might happen and
make sure that it was a valid method
so as you can see here the gray box is
the tritonex only this is the protocol
that we had been running the light blue
box is the heated dilution the light
yellow is a heated dilution and then
lights with Triton the dark blue is
where we heat about the stock tube made
a solution heated the dilution and then
the dark yellow is where heated the
stock made a dilution heated the
dilution and laced it with tritonex as
well
they all look okay that's the end of
that story so we've decided to move
forward with heating just to make things
a little bit safer and it does actually
improve the sensitivity in some cases
next thing we want to do is evaluate the
volume titration so can we bring down
the volume to not only save costs but
optimize throughput
so we looked at the what we're doing now
is the 20 microliter reaction we brought
down a 10 a 12 and a six I'll show in
the table in the next how we did this so
the strategy here was to cut the volume
of the final reaction but
keep the actual final neat saliva volume
static over the two reactions so you can
see in the 20 microliter reaction
because we're using a 25 dilution and
five microliters of that it's 1.25
microliters of meat saliva so say it's
one copy per microliter of sarcov2 and
then we're adding in 1.25 copies
same thing with the 12. so we increase
the amount of saliva being put in
percentage-wise we increase the Triton
percentage
decrease the Triton volume so the Triton
percentage stays the same over but we're
able to add in more saliva and we assume
we're all adding in more copies of the
potential virus per microliter
um
six microliter reaction worked very well
and this is what we end up handing into
the X prize which is I again I'll talk
about in a little bit
I broke this one down by probe so you
can see N1 and N2 are the COV or again
RP is the human internal control 20
microliter average is the darkest one
and then 10 12 and 6 is the lightest one
well the CTS are slightly higher in the
six microliter for the COV probes
they're still well within a robust
positive
um
result here and all of them showed up
very very well 33 is about the lowest
that we saw for a CT here so I should
note that in the extraction protocols
you may be seeing CTS and the teens the
20s we don't get that with the
directional Isis the CTS are usually in
the 30s sometimes up to 38 and it's
still that's a positive so our cutoff is
40 over 40 triggers a retest under 40 is
a positive
so before we can test this in-house we
wanted to run some contamination testing
just to make sure that moving the tubes
through the building from the BSC to the
liquid Handler didn't introduce any
contamination we began with a
checkerboard on just a Pico green assay
using DNA and NTC um just te and water
uh actually then go back here so the top
is what the adapters look like in the
biomech the first plate we had the
biomech dispense and that plate got red
right away and then we ran the biomack
through the qpcr program that would be
running and then we ran that through a
plate again
um I don't have the data to show for
that because it was actually just
photographs of the Plate Reader
um but there was no contamination
detected there so we wanted to move on
to an all-way checkerboard contamination
test so because in the previous one an
NTC splashing into DNA wouldn't
necessarily show up so we need to do
this in an all-direction contamination
test so this year you can't see these
numbers don't really mean anything
except that the cob Pros were found
where we put the plasmid and the RP was
found where we put the RPP 30.
there was one well B10 that showed a
small amount of RP and it shouldn't have
so we brought the FAS in they did
calibration and Alignment we re-ran it
everything looked good no contamination
so back to the plasmid and saliva what
is our real LOD here because it's a lot
of the main hibbit which we already saw
neat saliva inhibits detection of COV
particles we wanted to see if there's a
threshold we can find where we can find
it and find
plasmid in Te but not in saliva
um it looks like it didn't really make
too much of a difference doesn't inhibit
inhibit too much so SP in this slide
means saliva plasmid underscore and then
the number of copies in the entire
reaction so sp1 for example would be
saliva plasmid with one copy spiked into
a normal saliva I should have mentioned
that we had pulled a bunch of normal
saliva samples at this point to try and
mitigate some of the between participant
heterogeneity that kind of exist in
saliva on the right hand side you can
see the te underscore and the number of
copies
of the plasmid that were there so while
we found positive results in some
replicates we didn't consistently find
it until
the 10 reaction whereas in Te we may be
able to find it in five so we're calling
10 our limit of detection
I just wanted to point out here
this is just looking at five and a
thousand copies of plasmid on the left
is the plasmid and te in the middle is
plasmid in 25 saliva and on the right of
the plasmid it meets the lava so you can
see in the five reaction five condition
it completely knocks out
the detection of the plasmid in the
Thousand it's there but you can see one
of the CTS is up near 40. so again more
um
more data that shows that neat saliva
can really inhibit this amplification
so this is just the graphic breakdown of
how we end up this is our final protocol
we collect the saliva heat and activate
it dilute it lysit
add it and duplicate if there's room run
qpcr and then analyze the data and then
I want to speak a little bit
yeah I want to speak a little on the
variants and the probes and the agility
that I spoke about in the beginning so
this is the nuclear capsid Gene this is
adapted from
scripts keeps uh they do a lot of
routine surveillance and they have this
outbreak.info
website is really cool if you want to
play with it
um so the yellow Parts here are where
our probes are amplifying those are the
sections you can see in the b117 at
position three is kind of close to where
the first probe is however we have
tested a b117 variant sample through
this essay and it still performs quite
well so what if a mutation comes up
where one of our probes are well it's
not going to be a big deal really to
design around it we already have one
in-house that we use as backup we've
tested and validated it and part of
what's going to be cool about PCR
testing in the future is keeping an eye
on potential emerging pathogens and I
think next time next time hopefully it's
not the next time but if there is we
would be more prepared and I already
have these things designed and
potentially valid
um RNA or something like that later
so I wanted to go into the X prize which
was
um
we were extremely fortunate to be able
to enter and
just sort of get access to a really cool
network of people this is the timeline
which you probably again can't see this
here but it started in July and then the
final winners were just announced I want
to say March maybe the end of February
um so it was a lot of stages through a
lot of
uh Innovation that people presented
there so we formed a team team lji and
we decided to throw our hats in the ring
and
through the X prize we were able to gain
a lot more clinical validation of our
tests or our screen so in the
semi-finals they sent us blinded plates
one interesting thing we found out is
this assay is completely incompatible
with PBS
we spiked plasmid and PBS we were
finding some weird results and we didn't
understand why we weren't getting any
positives in certain plates and then
went back and looked at the matrices and
our assay only worked on the saliva and
it worked quite well we had a bunch of
experiments planned to figure out why
that was but in the end did not have the
bandwidth to try and figure out why our
essay wasn't working on materials that
we didn't design our assay for well it
would be interesting it just it wasn't
something that we had the time to do so
in the semi-finals you can see our
sentient species were 94 and 100 and
then in the finals We There were 40
negatives 40 positives there in each of
these there was one that we are calling
a false negative they were inconclusives
meaning
it came back with one of the cob probes
or three but not all four
replicates so
um to be conservative we're still
calling it a false negative so this
would have triggered a retest in the
real world so in the end averaging these
two
uh test together we have a sensing
especially of 96 6 and 100.
the reaction volume one of the one of
the
things that X prize was looking for is
that the a test that's entered be
radically affordable so in a best case
scenario we would have everything
um designed out well we have the
reactions down to a dollar 22 which
includes all the saliva collection and
the batch controls
as well
and we were excited to find out that we
were one of the winning teams selected
and we are working on a deployment phase
coming soon where we do a larger scale
real world deployment
um so we're super excited about that
so I just want to go through the
objectives here the advantages and
disadvantages of saliva so saliva
everybody's got it it's easy to get from
people
um the quality remains good over
multiple days it's a stable sample even
though there's probably lots of rnases
existing in there
even after five days we could still find
everything that we were expecting to
find in any sample however it can be
difficult to get a quality sample
it can be viscous it contains Inhibitors
um as you saw a lot of them meet
saliva inhibited any amplification of
things so that's one thing that can be
difficult the CTS are higher though
with the clinical validation we learned
that at least with those samples it was
still very specific and sensitive
so RNA extraction free the there was
another team that used the same probes
and primers except they were using
extraction their sensitivity came back
at 100 meaning they didn't have that
inconclusive however this could be
mitigated if
we treated an inconclusive and reflects
it to an RNA extraction protocol
so I think that's something to get
around and again the the flexibility and
the agility of PCR based protocols is
that if you can determine what genes are
less likely to undergo a lot of
mutations or variants and design your
probes in there and that's probably a
wise move
yeah
so I want to go through the
acknowledgments and I really want to
thank Steve Wilson who is my boss and
our CEO and with the brains of the
aberration and a hugest cheerleader for
us John stillwagon who wrote our entire
reporting program
and had everything working in a matter
of I don't know weeks and especially I'd
like to thank the NGS core this is my
team
Arturo Hannah Kyle and Rosie who just
work like crazy doing all the what work
for this and keeping ngf core running at
the same time
um because that's that's our day job
I also want to go through and thank some
other people at lji first I want to
thank the Dave Porters who
just just cleaned and disinfected and
deconed and just made it a safe
environment for people to go into work I
know they worked so hard throughout this
entire pandemic and I just really like
to thank them for providing a safe
workplace for us
Ingrid Chris and Talia who got us worked
on the positive samples morog Shane
Susan Sonia who helped us share their
space and resources as well David
Melissa and Lisa's EHS biosafety and IRB
John Deanna and Janae from facilities
and then I'd like to thank the X prize
team as well Jeff Lisa and Chris and
then Brian Dan Karen Kaden and then our
clinical Partners who ran all this
testing for us with almost the Euro
training and just receiving a protocol
and being able to run it was just
amazing especially at biosa they were
incredible
um
so I'd just like to thank all these
people who helped us get through
this entire process and just really made
it this wild ride a little bit more fun
so thank you